la serre aux papillons a rouvert ses
portes à la queue-lez-yvelines après
trois mois de fermeture suite à la crise
sanitaire
les visiteurs peuvent de nouveau observé
ces insectes de toutes les couleurs sur
ce site de 720 m² maintenu à 28 degrés
avec 80 % d'humidité et la magie opère
toujours
c'est magnifique parce qu'il ya
tellement de pavillons différents et ils
ont vraiment pas peur de nous donc c'est
bien parce qu'on peut les observer et on
peut aussi les prendre en photos ils ont
leurs besoins le fait de voir les
papillons en liberté puisqu'il pour les
rues c'est la première fois qu'on vivait
cette expérience là en tout cas une
serre aux papillons qui a souffert
pendant l'épisode du kobe 19 la
structure créée en 1989 a perdu de
nombreux papillons
habituellement on a à peu près 700 entre
700 et 800 papillon dans la serre là si
on
on en a la moitié c'est bien là on a eu
des messages de fournisseurs qui
reprenne fortement les fortement les
commandes et les livraisons donc on
espère que l'on puisse réatteindrai ce
nombre de 700 à 800 papillon dans la
serre de nouvelles chrysalide devraient
être livrés dans les prochains jours
cette visite d'une heure environ dans
cette serre vous coûtera 5 euros pour
les enfants et 7 euros 50 pour les
adultes